that I Have a Dream speech gives me
goosebumps to this day and I take that
ethic very seriously and when I see it
violated it makes me angry and it makes
me sad
in the midst of a revolution it's like
there's a frenzy when the fog clears
you can see all all the things that were
done that were wrong
that were deeply wrong
there was
four billion dollars of aid for Farmers
with debt only if you are not white if
you're a white restaurant owner or a
white struggling farmer that loses
their Farm in the context of a recession
you are never going to forgive that you
were not treated on the basis of need
but you were treated on the basis of
race just like black people in America
have not forgotten redlining Jim Crow
where's this going well I don't know
that depends a lot on
the actions and The Bravery of millions
of individuals many of whom
will be watching this video
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of trigonometry on the road from
the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a brilliant
guest and returning to the show now in
person for the first time uh he is the
writer and musician and podcaster
comment Hughes welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me again yeah man
it's great to see you we are actually by
accident got a chance to hang out last
night we went to see a show at the
Comedy Cellar had a chance to chat a
little bit which is great because the
last time we had you on the show it was
summer of 2020 it was the peak of the
BLM right racial conversation that we
had at the time and we got a load of
your ideas and thoughts about the world
but one of the things we're starting to
find is people who talk about the stuff
that you talk about and that we talk
about it and who are willing like you
you to actually be public about it and
to speak out about it and risk things
usually there's like a reason or a set
of reasons why they do this it doesn't
just happen by accident so I guess the
question is like what's your back story
why why are you sitting in this chair
right now that's a good question I don't
know how much I can
answer it from the inside sometimes
people can sort of see you more
accurately from the outside than you can
see yourself but insofar as I understand
myself I think I
I was raised in a context where I really
did not care about race one way or the
other I was raised in a very diverse
upbringing
and uh
you know the consensus growing up was
the Martin Luther King ideal
and I lived that as a child very much I
had friends of every race and I didn't
think about race
and suddenly
2012 2013 2014 came around
and
people started telling me
you're a victim
and race really does separate you from
your friends that are white or Asian or
like this is an important feature of
your identity there are certain things
you can understand as a black person
that your your white friends can't and I
knew this to be instinctively wrong I
had lived enough I think
to know
that
race really is it's only as deep as you
want to make it or as deep as you choose
to make it
and
that it's it's wrong to make
to make it matter
and um
and so BLM hit
and at the time I was a musician and
mostly in jazz and I had friends of
every race in that community and we
really all connected on a deep level
over loving the same music which was
further Evidence
although I wouldn't might not have said
it this way at the time was further
evidence that
you know the Human family is not deeply
separated into races right like you can
connect
with someone of A different race so
deeply that you build a life with them
and marry them and have kids with them
right like you can do the most you can
have the most intimate relationships of
your life with people of A different
race and that happens every day's
routine right
so this new ideology
um when I went to Colombia I was I was
inundated with this new ideology with
which
and in the
in this segment of society that had the
least racism that I'd ever seen right
Columbia University Ivy League schools
as Progressive as as it possibly gets
right so Progressive that there are
posters on
on the walls of hallways that say well
Mexican instead of women right like
that's how in latinx you know like
so Progressive that there's a new
language like 10 steps left of the
democratic party that's how anti-racist
it was precisely in that space I was
hearing
um activist students say I experience
racism every day on this campus right I
was hearing them speak about
the level of racism in this environment
in in a way that I I would hear like my
grandparents speak about growing up
under Jim Crow
and that that cried out to me as like
something is amiss here something is
wrong
I I and I became very curious about what
that was Coleman just to stop me there
when they said that they were talking
about their experiences of racism on the
campus on the Columbia campus well well
what examples did they give
um
so I'm not I can't really recall so some
of them would be what would have been
called microaggressions a few years ago
uh more often they wouldn't give
examples at all
and
this is where or lived experience can
matter because if you're an outsider
reading a black Columbia student say I
experience racism every day you may not
know what to think of that you may say
well that's interesting she experiences
racism every day
as a black student at Columbia
that was you know
staying at till 2 A.M on on campus all
the time giving security guards plenty
of opportunities to be racist against me
and experience like near zero racism
like really close to zero maybe once uh
one anomalous experience in four years
right everything else was just
totally totally non-racist I knew that
it was a lie that these kids were
putting it on and that they were highly
incentivized to do so by the subculture
because
um
victimhood
became currency became social currency
and as social beings we are extremely
attuned to
how to elevate ourselves in status right
it's like
it's most of what we're built to do is
to so if you live in this in a
subculture where you are cool and and uh
High status precisely insofar as you can
persuade people that you're a victim of
oppression racism sexism homophobia Etc
people respond to those social
incentives and I I could see that that
was that's what was going on
so you see this which is cool I think a
lot of people see it but there's another
piece to my first question to you which
is why are you someone who feels
strongly enough about it to actually put
themselves on the line over it
uh that's a good question I think
I I really took it seriously
when I was taught Martin Luther King's
words as a kid I Have a Dream speech
gives me goosebumps to this day and I
take that
ethic very seriously and when I see it
violated it makes me angry and it makes
me sad and
when I see that people are
are hesitant and fearful to speak up in
defense of it it makes me feel that I I
I ought to fill that role common you've
used the word violated which is a very
strong word and obviously you're a super
smart guy you've used that word
for a reason what do you mean by the
word violated
did I say violated yeah violated them
MLK yeah yeah
well
the the ethic is that the principle is
that race
race actually does not matter and the
people to make who who do make race
matter are making an error this is
precisely what was the problem with
white supremacy Jim Crow slavery and all
of the Myriad abuses that black people
suffered throughout the history of
America from even before its founding
was that
uh
people made race matter when it should
not have and judge people not on the
basis of their individual abilities but
on the accident of their birth into a
particular race right that is the error
it always has been
and
uh that principle has been violated in
the name of
paying black people back for history
essentially
um
the idea is that we're going to make up
for all that all the horrible white
supremacy of the past by
flipping the Discrimination as as
Ibrahim Kennedy says I imagine your
viewers are familiar with
Abram Candy's book you know the the
remedy to pass discrimination is present
discrimination
a few anti-racists say it say The Quiet
part out loud but that but candy does
and the idea is we are going to
discriminate against white people as a
group in order to make up for all of
what was what has been done to Black
Americans
in the past which requires
a violation of the Civil Rights ethic
the Civil Rights ethic was not to
discriminate against white people not to
reverse the logic of Jim Crow it was to
to uh to start anew right from a race
neutral perspective
and
we can you know
all of the problems of intergenerational
poverty and
um
really dealing with a disadvantage and
privilege and economic inequality we can
really address those in a race neutral
framework in a framework that does not
say you're this color so you're going to
get you're going to get this policy and
you're this color so you're going to get
this policy
um you know we we have people we know
how much money people make
it's possible to do any program that
could be race based to do it based on
income in class
and it that's a much closer proxy to who
is actually disadvantaged right in
society to begin with and it's fairer
and um and so that's what I mean when I
say the the ideal has been violated yeah
and do you think that one of the reasons
that this way of doing it I mean one of
the things we've chanted in on the show
in many different formats with many
different people is the shift of the
left from working people to certain
racial and other minority groups uh do
you think one of the reasons is that
it's easier to motivate people in this
way race runs deeper with people than
something like class uh it's easier to
cultivate a sense of victimhood for
example within a group based on their
tribal sort of ethnicity or whatever
than it is on something a bit more
abstract like class
I do think that's right I think one of
the mistakes that
the marxists of the past made was
thinking that
class could be made such a Salient an
important identity to people of many
different races that they would
spontaneously unite and really feel one
with
members of different ethnicities
different languages because they were
both poor
and I think it turns out that
human tribal psychology is more easily
activated much more easily activated on
the basis of ethnicity
than it is on the basis of class to the
point where you have people that have
almost nothing in common
you know like a poor black person from
the hood
right has actually very little in common
I would argue
I would say he has more in common with a
poor white person from the trailer park
from the proverbial trailer park then he
does with a black person like myself
that grew up uh with wealth
right
so and yet it seems to be easier to get
people to connect on the basis of race
and ethnicity than on the basis of class
it's amazing isn't it how we've seen
race relations regress it's really sad
can you explain to us some of the things
that I start all the policies that have
started or have been spoken about that
they're going to be implemented in the
US in the park in either the past few
years or the upcoming few years they're
an example of this
oh sure yes so
so we can start with uh
the pandemic era Aid policies that have
been distributed on Race so there's the
American Rescue plan which was a two
trillion dollar bailout at the height of
the pandemic in 2021 to help Americans
that were struggling to help businesses
you know part of that was 28 billion
dollars for restaurants that were going
out of business every day
and the program was done in such a way
that
anyone not white was put to the front of
the line automatically in so-called
priority groups if you're white
it took a lot more work to get into that
category
um
there was four billion dollars of aid
for Farmers with debt
only if you are non-white zero of that
money was available to you if you were a
white farmer with debt and there was
Zero money in the bill available to you
in general right so it was just a pot of
money only for non-white farmers
um
and again if you are
if you're a white restaurant owner or a
white struggling farmer that loses
their Farm in the context of a recession
where people are losing their businesses
every day and your business is your life
absolutely you are never going to
forgive that you were not treated on the
basis of need
but you were treated on the basis of
race just like black people in America
have not forgotten redlining Jim Crow
um you know convict Leasing
all of these policies that affected
black Americans
have not been forgotten and in many
cases have not been forgiven and we
should not expect that these kind of
things are going to be forgotten or
forgiven
and uh certainly not going to be excused
on the basis of paying for other
people's sins
fine completely badly when you were
expect when you were talking about this
and when you're talking about it now
but you see the people who come up with
these ideas do they not realize this
really pisses people off quite rightly
and there will be a backlash
yeah they it's interesting I think
I think many people are able to
ignore
the ignore the backlash in two ways so
in in one way they will just actually
not look at it right like a lot of
a lot of I think top Democrat Party
operatives would not actually like these
policies if they look them in the face
it's just they kind of sweep it under
the rug they don't report about it they
don't watch the Tucker Carlson segment
about it because why would they watch
that and they soft pedal it if you bring
it up they say oh it wasn't really that
it was something softer they used
language the orwellian euphemisms of
priority group and historically
disadvantaged group
um which you know all of which is
intended to soften the truth which is
that you gave people money limited money
because of the race that they happen to
be born into and you denied it to others
on the basis of race period
and so there's that but then there's
also
um the way this will be reported on is
the groups that
are part of the backlash well they are
maga-backed groups right so there's a
magabact lawsuit against the farmer bill
right when you read this in the New York
Times They will make sure to front load
for you and therefore prime prime you as
a reader so like I like I don't like
Mega I don't like Trump I voted against
him twice so when I read that it's a
Maga backed lawsuit that's priming me to
say oh well we their anger doesn't count
well a bunch of racists being racist
they're a bunch of races being racist
exactly whereas if you were to meet one
of these people a white restaurant owner
struggling
um who may have had no you know you may
assume this person had quote unquote
White Privilege or whatever but you know
nothing about this person's background
like he might he might have struggled
just as much or more than a black
restaurant any given black restaurant
owner
um and
and you meet him and you look in his
eyes and you go to his restaurant and
and you see that this person was
reported on
as basically a quote angry white guy
in a way that was intended to to let you
dismiss his anger as invalid I mean you
know and by the way what was the Civil
Rights Movement but a long overdue
backlash to Jim Crow laws that's what it
was so the the language of backlash I
think is it's intended to make you feel
that this is that people are reacting
and that they're coming from a place of
anger that's invalid
and I I think it should that anger
should be seen as
a
a
like a perfectly predictable consequence
of people being discriminated against
the Discrimination should stop right
well this is what I was going to ask you
about because
I talk about it in my book uh about one
experience that I had in the UK when I
was invited to participate in a in a TV
discussion of these similar issues
um and afterwards one of the pre was a
panel of several people and afterwards
one of the presenters during the ad
break uh looked at me and they went I'm
so glad there weren't any white British
people here to be involved in this
conversation mm-hmm
and I was completely stunned by this
and it was only when I got home later I
was like why would they say that like
they know I don't agree with this
imagine I recorded that and I put that
out or whatever right
um
and then it was only when I got home
later that I realized
this is normal to these people
it's this way of thinking is normal now
how do you sometimes wonder how like
when because when you talk about MLK and
that that speech and the ideal that's
what I grew up with that's what I that's
where I I thought that was the
destination that you were all working
towards yes and here we are not only
have we not made progress towards that
we are actually going back on that how
the hell did we get here
yeah I mean that that is a deep question
um I think there are a few factors
so let's be clear the backlash the
let's say the the race obsession
goes back a long time it was there
during MLK's time right you you had you
had Malcolm X you had the Black Power
movement you had the Black Panthers you
had an intellectual tradition
um starting uh with critical race Theory
you know in the 70s and 80s and the
precursors to critical race theory in
the 70s which came out of more out of
the black power tradition which were
saying even back then
no race really does matter it
intrinsically matters because of
you know white the country being steeped
in white supremacy being born with white
supremacy being stamped from the
beginning with slavery it will never not
matter and let's drop this whole naive I
don't see race yeah that that
strain has always been there it was just
it was Fringe it was small right it
wasn't
it wasn't necessarily
the ruling ideology of every Elite
University it wasn't a major factor in
the Democratic Party
so the question is what change to allow
the idea that race matters that race
should be infused in every policy what
allowed that
to
really dominate
society and dominate cultural
institutions
and um you know that's something I
haven't totally figured out the answer
to but
some parts are of an answer I think are
one
I think the decline of Christianity has
something to do with it because
um
Martin Luther King was a Christian and
he spoke in Christian language right he
would say in Christ there's neither
Greek nor Jew black nor white Bond nor
free
and what that meant to an audience of
Christians black white and other was
that
we're all made in the image of God God
is the Transcendent story that
unites us right like how does it matter
that you're black and that I am that you
know that you're white
if we're both Christian if we're both in
the image of God and that was a very
powerful thing
that was a very powerful compelling
argument actually that persuaded a lot
of people
uh obviously Christianity is on the
decline and I'm not a Christian I wasn't
raised with it at all but it's much more
difficult
to get people behind a narrative of
common Humanity when you don't have a
religious backing when you're just
saying
oh you know we're all one we're so that
that doesn't tend to be as compelling if
if there's not a religious
element to it it's it's a more difficult
cell and then I think people revert into
tribes
and
and so I think it has something to do
with the decline of Christianity I think
has something to do with the rise of
social media and how fast ideas can
spread how fast videos can spread and
and so forth hey Francis do you go on
the internet to look at naughty stuff
yeah is it stuff that you'd be
embarrassed to show your friends
yeah is it stuff that would get you
canceled yeah well next time you decide
to be naughty and watch more
trigonometry you need to use expressvpn
it doesn't matter mate because I use
incognito mode it doesn't matter what
mode you use or how many times you clear
your browsing history your internet
service provider can still see every
single website you've ever visited
that's why even when you're at home you
should never go online without using
expressvpn my career is finished there
there you'll have to leave trigonometry
can't be helped anyway it doesn't matter
who your internet service provider is
isps in the US can legally sell your
information to ad companies expressvpn
is an app that reroutes your internet
connection through their secure service
so your ISP can't see the site you visit
absolutely first
expressvpn also keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time
you won't even realize you have
expressed VPN on it runs seamlessly in
the background and is so easy to use all
you have to do is tap one button and
you're protected what am I gonna do
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
TV so there's no excuse for you not to
be using it go on Francis do the last
bit
if you don't want to end up like me
protect your online activity today with
a VPN rated number one My Business
Insider visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com trigger and you can get
an extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
[Music]
expresvpn.com trigger expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more
do you think one of the things that is
so powerful about these ideas and this
ideology
is it just Taps into trauma you know
what I mean because
like everybody's had bad things happen
to them you know everybody you know
particularly if you're an ethnic
minority background or your working
class you can name
specific instances where you might have
been discriminated against or people
were racist to you or maybe if we're
going to be generous people use clumsy
language towards you
and once you start tapping into people's
emotions they stop thinking logically
and they start reacting emotionally
and that's never a good thing when you
react emotion in a situation and it
encourages that right right no it does
um
I saw a lot of this when I was at
Columbia of
of a kind of
social incentive to remember and magnify
any real experiences of discrimination
you've had so
I even saw this when I was in high
school we once did a racial affinity
group
this was just the beginning of the woke
Revolution really maybe 2012 where we
all the black students at my high school
we got for a little you know an hour a
couple hours we got together
you know
directed by the school and you know
talked about black stuff whatever and
but what basically what it became
was a competition to find the worst
thing that had ever been said to you or
done to you and it was it was
interesting to me because
it felt it felt
it felt like the wrong way to actually
deal with
discrimination right it felt like it
felt very very much like
an echo chamber
and obviously the argument for that kind
of thing is oh so we we want a safe
space to like talk about the time that
um you know somebody grabbed my Afro
right like that's the kind of thing that
would happen that a white kid would do
that that wouldn't have happened if you
were at a more diverse school where
people or an afro wasn't a weird thing
to have right it's like okay so we need
to be we need to talk about that
and being around only around other black
people is is a you know a safe space
where you could do that uh that that's
sort of the argument for it and there's
something to that but because what it
very quickly becomes is just
how
how like how how how much can we just
crank the dial on our own sense of
grievance and like nurse it nurse the
grievance so that it becomes bigger in
our minds
and that's what happens when you're in
an echo chamber we see that with
political Echo Chambers on the right and
the left
um
and that's what it is to be in an echo
chamber like whatever it started with it
gets louder
and and then we send ourselves back into
the world with this sense of grievance
that has become bigger because we've
nurtured it
and I don't think that that's actually
the right way to deal with trauma or
it's a very tempting way to deal with it
but it's actually not the mature or or
healthy way to deal with it and one of
the things that strikes me about this
Coleman is like we've been in New York
for a few days now just walking around
or sitting down having lunch outside
watching people go by
it must take an extraordinary amount of
like effort to divide people on racial
lines in the city because it's like
everybody's you know like you see people
of every race dating people of every
other race and it's like it's like it's
incredibly
mixed and you can see that to the people
that are walking down the street their
races are really unimportant you can
just see that by the way they by who
they're with and how they behaved you
know what I mean like you're not seeing
people hang out with only people of
their race at all and yet here we are
where the elite discourse
and maybe this is where the problem is
the sort of conversations that people
have about this issue are incredibly
divided in a city that doesn't look at
how how does that work well yeah I think
there's a very big difference between
the way Elites think can talk about this
and the way uh the the rest of people
think and talk about this
which is not to say I mean there's a lot
of actual
bigotry and tribalism out there you know
I don't want my daughter marrying a such
and such I don't know you know there's a
lot of that out there among non-elites
um but of all Races by the way of all
Races that's right it's it's often
talked about as if this is you know one
of my
one of my gripes is
if you were to ask me on the basis of
lived experience
where I've encountered the most racism
like what groups I've encountered the
most personal racism directed at me from
is actually not white Americans it would
more be like immigrant groups from like
other countries yeah in terms of like
who I've heard say the most racist stuff
as an immigrant from an Eastern European
country that does not surprise me right
and it's not yeah it's not not even
white immigrants right you know yeah so
again neither here nor there the point
is racism is a sin committed by all all
groups of people and yet it's talked
about as if white people
invented and are the only ones that
perpetuate it which I think is a very
a very
um
that's the kind of idea you can only
really believe if you've if you're like
over educated and haven't really lived
in very many places in the world you
know it's like your only experience of
life is like your ivy league degree
um
if you if you actually live in the world
you're going to encounter bigotry from
you're going to realize it's a human
foible it's a human sin yeah yeah
but you know
all the examples that you've given I
found it very interesting have all a lot
of it has come from your University you
went to Colombia yeah yeah well there's
a big influence on me you know I think
it was um
it was kind of a culture shock in a way
I mean in one sense I was exactly the
kind of kid that would go to Colombia so
it wasn't
my whole life was tracking to go to an
Ivy League school so it was totally to
be expected and it was only a 30 minute
drive from where I grew up
but it was a culture shock
in the sense that
I don't think I had ever been around
that much concentrated Elite privilege
at once
and what about this room
and um
and and again I think maybe the fact
that I was a musician was part of it
because and I really saw myself as a
musician first
because music is
somewhat meritocratic right it's like if
you're incredible at the saxophone
you're gonna get into Juilliard or what
like you just
and it's not total total meritocracy but
it's like quite close more like sports
in that sense people come from all walks
of life and end up you end up in the
same room as people from all different
classes all different races
and you you're bonding over this thing
and that that's um
that's the kind of environment where
race loses its importance
um or is he
yeah we're race loses it's it's
important that's exactly like this it's
like that Bond of both being on stage
overcomes anything else that's right
that's right and so to go from that as
the defining
like you know ecosystem of my social
life to Colombia where
it was like all of a sudden
there's like all these incredibly guilty
white people that like are terrified of
like saying the wrong thing around me
and I'm I'm very aware of the the social
power that I have in any given situation
like at any time I can pull the race
card and it's going to be viewed as
valid by enough people
that I can do that and that's that's a
that's a very very tempting power to to
to to to to wield and then I could see
other black students doing that a lot
you know like when you're back into a
corner you play the race card and
and then and then there was this
phenomenon of like quietly coming out to
other students as not woke
right it was like there would be the
first moment where you quietly like tell
someone like I'm kind of like not down
with the whole this whole like thing
like
and then they would admit to you like me
too and it would be this moment of
essentially coming out and
um that is something I had not
experienced ever
and it was it was uh
I I I I became of necessity extremely
curious about it because I was like what
the hell is going on
so it was in a way it was a kind of a
culture shock and I talk about it so
much because the Genesis of me writing
about this issue
it's like I I used to when I was at
Columbia student I used to write you
know like thousands of words
in a Google doc
to nobody but myself just trying to
figure out why kids were speaking like
it like we were living in Jim Crow in
the precisely in the most privileged
most non-racist
place I'd ever been
so Coleman let me ask you this
oh
we had when we first had you on in the
summer of 2020
that was a peak
at least in this period of time of the
the divisiveness the tensions the
all of that where do you think we are
now
well we're we're definitely we have
descended from the peak 2020 as you say
it was the peak of
um
of racial bullying frankly
of horrible ideas like defund the police
actually getting some traction
of people
being
fired for
the slightest offenses and for
non-offensies at all
people losing friendships over
disagreeing about race
um
and and uh yeah I mean we all remember
it I think it was
in the midst of a revolution it's like
there's a frenzy there's a frenzy where
people actually can't think straight and
then when the fog clears
you can see all all the things that were
done that were wrong that were deeply
wrong
and it all looks much it looks worse in
retrospect
but at the time it just it seemed to be
what was called for at the moment and
there were so many people fired and
treated unfairly for saying
really the the most minimal criticisms
of the black lives matter movement for
example
and um
and where are we now I think we're
certainly in a better place than we were
then but that's not saying much right to
me
and you can see this in the actual data
on Google Search terms for things like
white privilege
or any other term associated with woke
um you'll see the trend line is like no
mentions until 2014.
spikes and then 2020 it goes way up and
then it kind of has come down since then
but we're still not where we were even
before the the Great awokening
so
um
yeah I mean I think it's gotten better
in the past two years but
from a peak that was absolutely
crazy I mean yeah you know
every business in New York City was
boarded up
you know boarded up several times for
months
and
you had major media figures and
politicians
saying that that's okay
or it's called for
um
so from that
peak of irrationality yeah we've gotten
a bit better but
do you know what I'm for sure about the
whole thing you just spoke about
Colombia no I know people who went to
Colombia I know the grades that you
needed to get into Colombia I know what
it takes
to get into an Ivy League education
these are the academically the brightest
and best and yet they just ingest this
whole stuff without questioning without
interrogating it without thinking for
themselves
how does that work you're meant to be
the smartest
surely that doesn't that mean that
you've got the best mind in order to
challenge these ideas and find out the
flaws in the argument and the logic
unfortunately I think that
intelligence is not that correlated
correlated with your ability to get to
the truth
about something which is to say
tribalism is much more powerful than
intelligence right like you they've done
studies
where they show this it's like
you show a person with a very high IQ
but who is part of say the liberal Echo
chamber and you give them some facts
about guns and they will just come to
the conclusion
the scripted left conclusion the right
wing guy will come to the scripted
right-wing conclusion
you know whatever level of IQ often like
the higher IQ you are the more you're
just able to find reasons why your party
line is the right one
um and again like you will you will find
a million studies where they'll have
Biden and Trump say the same sentence
and Democrats will disagree with it when
Trump said it but agree with it when
when Biden says it and and Republicans
will do the same thing
and they will do that no matter how
smart they are you could you get a 1600
on the SAT and it doesn't actually make
you less likely to to have partisan bias
so
I think the sad truth is intelligence is
not that much of a bulwark against
partisan bias well that would seem to be
the reality of what we're going through
um so look we've got uh
we're going backwards in terms of MLK's
dream as you say our Elite institutions
are pumping out students who
've bought into it despite their
intelligence as you say again where is
this going
well I don't know that depends a lot on
the actions and The Bravery of millions
of individuals
many of whom
will be watching this video
um I mean which is to say it depends
on
um
every single person's ability to
stand up for values and and reason and
speaking up
when it's difficult
um
you know that there's there will come a
time where something is happening in
your workplace or in your friend group
or in your marriage
where you know something something is
going on that's wrong ethically and that
violates your values but if you speak up
about it you could potentially pay a
price a big social price
and
um you know there will come across roads
and hopefully you will find that
listening to
podcasts like trigonometry or my own
conversations with Coleman or you know
can give you the language to articulate
your points the point you want to make
to the relevant people in a way that
communicates your good faith but gets
the point across
and the more people do that the more
people speak up
um I think the more the better this
situation gets so where we're going is
going to depend on a lot of people's
ability to be brave in the face of
uh difficult situations and what do we
do with institutions like Colombia very
prestigious
you know it's a seat of learning etc etc
but it's pumping out these students who
are just regurgitating this narrative
what do we do with this place well we
should support the professors and
students there that are committed to
free speech and Viewpoint diversity and
there are many
um
the phenomenon we're fighting here is
not that
you know it's not that 50 of students
hate free speech and diversity it's that
five percent of students hate it and 95
are terrified of them
and so is the institution yes
petrified right
um
to the point where you know you have the
president of of Columbia University a
free speech scholar Lee Bollinger First
Amendment scholar one of the foremost
and in his commencement speech this past
year
he um
she basically said I know I'm a free
speech scholar but I'm actually going to
talk about how there's a bit too much
free speech misinformation is is
horrible and we really should be
censoring a lot of stuff
so
um
so yeah and and listen you know if he
had said the opposite if he had gone up
there and give a full give a
full-throated defense of free speech he
would have been making his own life a
living hell
for the foreseeable future you know so
there's a but I'll push back on that
isn't that his job to make his life a
living hell isn't that the the role that
he needs to play it's a role he ought to
play yes it's the role he ought to play
so your question what do we do we
support
organizations like heterodox Academy
which are
um doing good work to support Viewpoint
diversity
institutions of Higher Learning
and
um maybe support the more experimental
universities that are coming around uh I
don't know too much about them but I
think University of Austin and yeah
there's a couple
that you may know about that are trying
to innovate in the space of
College
uh colleges you know it's a
very difficult to innovate right it's
like you're kind of just stuck with the
incumbents in
the college space so I support the
experiments and support the people
fighting for Viewpoint diversity and
Free Speech Coleman let's talk about
culture a little bit because uh we were
talking before we started about how we
had the opportunity to meet one of our
big supporters and one of the the points
he made he was sort of explained to us
why he decided to support our show over
other very very good people who do good
work in this era and one of the things
she said is culture is really important
uh entertainment is very important
because in addition to doing these
interviews we also do like uh live
streams where we joke about the issues
of the day and it's humorous and it's
offensive and all of that right and he
was sort of making the point that the
the work of
creating a healthier conversation around
all of your subjects depends also on the
entertainment side of things and you are
obviously a musician how do those two
things link up how do you see the role
of of entertainment and culture in this
conversation
yeah that's a good question I mean so so
I'm a trombonist and a rapper and I've
been releasing music videos
I've released three music videos this
year the first one was called blasphemy
and um in that song I kind of dealt with
some themes of free speech and
um speaking your mind and
self-censorship and
um
it's interesting because I think the
the entertainment world is in a bit of a
pickle because
it's in frankly the same situation that
that Elite institutions in general are
which is that
you know five percent of people have a
kind of a veto on any
any new Netflix show any new movie any
um
which is to say what the market actually
wants is pretty much what the market has
always wanted
the market doesn't really want
preachy woke
music or
movies or anything and that's proven
over and over again by what sells even
even when the market wants um
even when you have rappers that really
do come from like a racial Justice
perspective like a Kendrick Lamar
his latest album he you know is the
whole thing is he is rejecting being
this
sort of socially conscious
voice right he's like I'm going to tell
you about all the [ __ ] up things about
me
and I'm not going to be your hero like
I'm I'm flawed I'm
you know like I'm an [ __ ]
I'm not your
like I'm not you're I'm not the
intersectional hero you're looking for
is kind of what his new album is and
um there's obviously Kanye still doing
extremely well saying he's what he's
saying
um
and and so I think what I what I have to
imagine is going on in a lot of like
writers rooms for shows is
you have good writers that want to
ignore woke
and just make a good TV show whatever
that means like
like you would have if the year was like
2011. and if the jokes are going to be
offensive they're going to be offensive
but but they're going to be funny
and then you have a small minority of
people
in in those rooms that is saying oh well
you can't say that that's that's racist
that's sexist
um we need
uh we need more
actors of color in this scene or we need
whatever
even if it doesn't fit the story
and
basically
what what you have to do is sort of
decide between whether you just want to
make a good show for its own sake
or you want to Cave to a small minority
of people that have a lot of cultural
power right now
and make your show less funny make it
less engaging make it less relatable
and and and I but I think for what it's
worth I think a lot of people are doing
that effectively like even a show like
Euphoria for example
which um some people might say is like a
woke show I don't think it is it's just
it happens to have a trans main
character
it's like they
they say the word [ __ ] on that show
unapologetically they like there's one
scene where
Rue was like talking about how
talking sort of Praise in a praiseworthy
way about Christians and like
even saying something nice about
anyway the overall tenor of the show is
violates a lot of tenets of wokeness
and I actually think that's why it's so
popular among gen Z is because
at the end of the day people never want
preachy art whether that is preachy
Christian right-wing art moralist art or
preachy far left woke art people want
art that Taps into deep themes of human
nature
and that goes as much for for Gen Z as
it does
for Millennials and
and Boomers and stuff you know so I
think
the the good thing about
the profit motive is that you can't
really be successful if you're
ideological
you're you know as an Entertainer your
ID your ideology has to be to entertain
at all costs pretty much like to make a
good show you know Atlanta is another
great example
um
Donald Glover received a lot of backlash
from from the woke over his reparations
themed episode where he actually showed
in this kind of black mirror-esque way
what reparations might look like if you
actually had black people tracing their
ancestors back to like
specific
like what would that actually look like
and when you see it you can't help but
think oh my God this is a nightmare this
is like
and and so
you know an episode of Atlantis showed
that and got a lot of backlash but again
Atlanta is an extremely successful show
and it's not anti-woke either
necessarily it's just orthogonal to woke
it like ignores he's trying to make
really interesting shows and because of
that he can't really be married to any
ideology
because here's the thing is that great
art shows a complexity of life right it
shows a nuances it shows how actually
this simplistic way of looking at the
world
it's it's it doesn't reflect life that's
why it doesn't work I remember watching
um who do you think you are which is a
British program where they take a
celebrity and they look back over there
you know over their ancestry their
ancestry and they they had on this uh
mixed race woman former athlete and they
look back and it turns out that one of
her great great grandfathers who was
black in the Caribbean owned slaves at
one point and she was devastated and
really upset and to me that seemed
really incongruous because it that's got
nothing to do with you
you know this idea that we have to look
back and somehow by Looking Back
hundreds of years we're going to be able
to solve the problems of now
it it just seems bizarre to me
you know it doesn't it just doesn't seem
to fit and
I guess the problem is is
do you think we're ever going to get to
a place where we're going to stop
talking about art being woke or not do
you know what I mean we didn't have
these conversations 10 or 15 years ago
we just judged the art whether it was
Cinema or or film or film or theater
whatever it may be just another person
who made it was a pedophile yeah exactly
but on its own merits
yeah well we're entering an age
of uh well
we're witnessing the birth of a new
major ideology quasi-religion
and you think both you think we're just
getting started
I don't know I don't know
um it seems to have some staying power
and in the 1950s you know we've very
much did Judge art by whether it was
Christian or not
you know that was a huge deal in in
America at least
um and it was a huge deal for
entertainers because
they had
very clear ways in which they could
violate
the the Mandate that all art must be
Christian
and must not offend the Christian
base
and Comics rebelled against that and got
punished for it socially in the 60s and
nutty Bruce and
but I think you know in the maybe 80s
and 90s and 2000s the power of
Christianity waned in the culture
especially in the in blue America
and there was some political correctness
stuff in the 90s but it wasn't it didn't
really have staying power
it it was confined to certain Elite
spaces
and uh in the 2000s yeah I mean I don't
remember having too many conversations
or you know even in like 2010 I don't
remember having too many conversations
like was this movie woke or was it
anti-woke like was this
was this episode transgressive of like
oh like
is this take canceled it's like people
will say that oh like I have a canceled
take it's just like oh
like whatever
um which was like oh Top Gun was really
good like is that canceled
um
so yeah I think I think we're going back
into an era where
there is a an ideology that is
very important kind of the way
Christianity was important
in the 50s and every individual
filmmaker musician songwriter TV writer
artist will have to make a decision of
whether they want to and are willing to
violate certain doctrines to make good
art and some of them are going to answer
that nope like I I got a family I'm not
going to do anything that rocks the boat
others are going to rock the boat in all
the right ways and I think they'll be
rewarded for it by
uh by the masses
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
comment on another note do you think we
can ever truly separate art from the
artist we've seen you know a raft of you
know celebrities great artists
you know behave appallingly and
abominably and people were saying you
know we should get rid of them which
they should be taking off Spotify we
shouldn't be listening to their music
well I mean where do you stand on this
because it's not as
it's you know there are nuances to this
argument aren't there
um I don't know I think
I'm kind of a Live and Let Live guy so
if you can't separate the art from the
artist then don't listen to that artist
yeah yeah but I I can guarantee you I
listened to Michael Jackson all the time
and I
I never think of
what he probably did to children
and I like I never condone it more in my
head it doesn't even occur to me which
is to say I can separate
the art from the bad parts of the artist
in that case and if I couldn't then I
would just stop listening to it
and get on with my [ __ ] life and I
wouldn't demand that other people be
just like me that's an insane and
narcissistic way of going through the
world
another thing that's interesting to me
and we were talking about it with a
comedy club promoter here in New York
last night is somewhat like Louis CK and
I'm and I sort of asked him like what
was your take on that why did you let
him keep playing your comedy club and he
was like well if I had a bartender who
got accused of something with no
conviction in court or anything like
that I wouldn't fight them a union would
never allow you to fire someone
yeah because they've been accused of
something but on the other hand I also
think do you think that in a situation
where people you know are getting away
with things
we're trying to feel our way towards
having it but like for example there
were parts of me too Igor Harvey
Weinstein absolutely I'm glad that
happened do you know what I mean like
it's not so I guess what I'm saying is
do you think that there's some good to
all of this too like we're making
progress on some things while maybe
going too far in the process or do you
think this is all bad no the metoo
movement was definitely partly good
because
it was uh what was shocking to many
people that a guy like Harvey Weinstein
could get away with what he was doing
for that long in the modern era I think
a lot of people thought that that was a
thing of the distant past rather than
the present
and it took it took that much cultural
power to get to give people the courage
to
come out and and like fight this guy who
had so much power and there were some
others like that and then inevitably
inevitably as it always does it went it
went way too far pretty quickly
and the opportunists came in and
um
the dishonest people came in to cash in
on on the trend
and get their 15 seconds of Fame and and
as like I said as it always does in
times of revolutionary Frenzy
people suspend all the important
principles of due process and reason and
hearing both sides
and it all looks much worse in
retrospect than it does at the time
right like
um
trying to think of a of a pretty oh
Louie's a perfect example right
um
You Know She's accused of something
that happened
you know many years ago before he was
famous
and no one wants to hear his side of it
right like no one is interested in
hearing his side of it and
from his side it's
it's really
it's what he was accused of doing was
actually not that bad on his telling and
on on their telling there was something
sketchy about what he did right and this
is the kind of thing we normal normally
settle in a court of law if a crime is
being alleged and people go to prison on
false charges people appeal there's a
hole we have a whole legal system set up
precisely because situations like this
are so complicated and so easy to run
into his mistakes
but in the frenziness of the moment
people are like
it's like how grasshoppers become
locusts
uh and seem like totally different
animals right when there's a
revolutionary frenzy going on humans
stop behaving like humans we start
behaving like locusts and we just swarm
and bypass all of our our better
judgments
and um
and in retrospect you can look back and
see how is it that people were so
horrible to him
but
again again it's just
it's how we behave in in times of frenzy
the reason me too always made me feel
uncomfortable right from the start is
the allegations yeah exactly I was
worried that I was going to go down
but thank you I've got great lawyers
Coleman here we are
[Laughter]
I've got to get that sweaty white man
energy now uh but no like it's just that
the moment you have
a group of people
who feel that they can get Justice
and there's no checks there's no
balances there's no ability really for
the person accused of this to come back
and to be listened to
all of a sudden you're not getting
Justice what this looked like
and that's not to say that there were
people who you know like Weinstein
obviously awful awful awful
but it looked like Fury and revenge and
when that happens revenge and Justice
they're two very different things yes
yeah they are
and um
the problem is that it becomes a bug
Light for dishonest people
if you send out a signal to the whole
world you say Okay normally we do the
due process we do due diligence on your
claims but right now starting now we're
going to suspend all of that
there's a lot of people out there that
are going to say ah this is my chance
this is my chance and they're going to
make something up they're going to
exaggerate the truth of a situation
and you're basically sending out a bat
signal for shitty people that want to
ruin someone's life
and that is the inevitable problem you
run into when you have even legitimate
and good
movements like me too
if you if you tell people if people
respond to incentives and this is what
you know revolutionaries never think
about they never think about or consider
that when you suspend
the rule of due process you're going to
attract inevitably you're going to
attract bad people
that see their chance
and they never account for that human
nature always includes those bad motives
those those bad people will always be
there
to make false accusations and to seize
their opportunity to climb in social
status as a result of valuing victimhood
and um
and so it's very important in those
moments to to fight for the rules of due
process and
all the principles that have made
um you know
Western democracies
fairly decent places to live
relative to the Alternatives well see
the thing is that philosophically
speaking the progressive ideology
doesn't believe in the existence of bad
people
there are no bad people in the
Progressive mindset there are people
who've been failed by the system that's
why they're they're behaving the way
that they are but they're not bad
they're not human beings are not prone
to bad behavior well what about straight
white men
well they are imbued with whiteness
which has been taught to them isn't it
right so so of course they think they're
bad people but it's because the way
they've been brought up and what we need
to do is undo the whiteness right that's
the argument
um so I think that's where a lot of the
progressive mindset goes awry it's based
on the idea that human beings are
infinitely perfectable and the only
reason human beings aren't perfect is we
haven't done enough social engineering
to get them to that point that's right
that's right Stephen pinker's book about
this was incredible and still the best
treatment of the subject that I know of
called the blank slate the modern denial
of human nature
this is the belief always popular among
revolutionaries of all eras
that
we are basically born with no nature
born inherently good
and only made bad by Society
only made selfish by Society
um whereas my view of human beings is
that
we are evolved by Evolution to all have
some degree of self-interest
and um and
we can never be made
we can never be made perfect we can
never even be made close to perfect that
there will always be a subset of humans
that want to be aggressive and violent
for its own sake
you know this is like one of the things
they like
you look into like Ted Bundy types and
you you always want to find something in
the background that explains who they
became and the truth is sometimes you
find it but sometimes you don't
sometimes people just are [ __ ] up
and and beyond that almost everyone is
imbued with a kind of
Baseline self-interest
as animals you know just like dogs have
a nature humans have a nature and
and it's tempting to believe that
because human our brains are malleable
and culture matters quite a lot which
all of which is true
that we have completely
uh We've completely
cast aside any kind of inherent nature
the truth is yes human beings more than
any other animal were capable of
learning a way of being from our culture
we learn a language from our culture we
learn
you know everything from the hand
signals we use when we talk to like what
kind of style of dress we think is cool
all of that is malleable
and can be learned and can and can
change over time but at the end of the
day there is still a core to us that is
given to us by our nature and that
nature includes self-interest
and it precludes the possibility of
systems like communism working on a
large scale right people are always
going to prefer their children to other
people's children their their biological
children for the most part their
biological family and are going to
privilege that over the rest of the
world and that's inherent it's not going
to change ever yeah so if you try to
make all a society like one family
you end up getting a disaster right if
you if your theory of criminal behavior
is that all of it is caused by social
circumstances and poverty and you think
you can get rid of the police and
address crime by
with like social programs you're gonna
you're gonna run into the fact that
actually some people commit crime
because it's fun
and because they can and this is one of
the thing this is one of the things that
really
grinded my gears about the 2020 riots
which is like okay why are the riots
happening
people will say okay yeah people are
you know George Floyd racial Injustice
you know Etc it's like okay well how
come all the rioters are young men
hmm that's interesting are only young
men the ones that are
affected by racial Injustice well no
how come older women aren't rioting and
are in fact begging the police to
intervene it's not that I say that's
interesting well maybe they're doing it
because rioting is fun and you've given
them a temporary pass to do it
I think sometimes people have to
become like more in touch with their
inner teenager and remember remember
how fun it was to just do like
mischievous [ __ ] for no reason
when you were like 16 right
that it is to me the Occam's razor
explanation is like
a lot of people would be if there were
no consequences if if you couldn't if
you couldn't possibly go to prison by
doing it how many people would just do
that type of [ __ ] just because because
it's fun yeah it'd be a lot of fun go
smash something up yeah young men have
been doing this for centuries for
centuries and and so I think the um
as a some philosophers would say the
explanandum which is like the thing to
be explained is reversed right people
think you have to explain
why people are like
uh you know crashing police car windows
with a bat
and to me I think basically you have to
explain why they aren't doing it more
often they're doing it because it's fun
yeah
um and more importantly in that
particular case is you gave them a post
is you give them a pass yeah there's a
socially acceptable pass which is that a
lot of people will for the moment we're
gonna say it's Noble violence is Noble
it's justified by what was done to
George Floyd and again you're standing
at the bat signal to all the people in
the world that want to have fun anyway
up all right we got a couple months
where we could do whatever we want let's
take this pass you know loot a store
because it's fun lootest or if some like
poor poor like Indian immigrant in
Harlem that has nothing to do with this
situation and just destroy his life
because it's fun
Coleman it's been great speaking with
you again about this stuff uh I don't
know what the [ __ ] this is going
but wherever it is I feel like your
voice is going to be one of the
important voices in shaping that
conversation oh thank you so we're glad
you've taken the time to do that on here
with us we really appreciate it it's
been a real pleasure to meet you
likewise in person uh the last question
as you know that we always ask before we
ask a couple of questions for locals
that only they will get to see uh is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
hmm that's a good question
um
so I I have been a little bit thinking
about this
question of birth rate Global birth
rates declining in all developed Nations
and Elon Musk has been talking about
this recently so I do think we have been
talking about it but prior to him
and and also someone like Matthew
Iglesias in his book one billion
Americans talks about this
which is just it seems to be close to a
law of
of
I don't know what you would call it
developmental economics or or what have
you that as societies become wealthier
and more educated people stop having
enough children to replace their numbers
naturally
um
and you see it in pretty much everywhere
on earth and the only places you don't
see it
are either societies that are that
haven't become wealthy yet
or the highly religious the ultra Ultra
Orthodox Jews the uh the Amish men and
Mennonites
um you know the Amish in America have
more than doubled their numbers in since
the 90s which is incredible right well
although the rest of America has receded
below replacement level
and and what happens when you don't use
condoms mate it's more happens when you
don't have entertainment mate yes
what else are you gonna do yeah but it's
interesting to think about the the
long-term
future of humanity right like if
everyone what we want to happen is that
poor countries
stop being poor like poor countries we
want that to happen so let's say that
happens and everywhere on earth now has
replaced it was below replacement level
except for
the ultra religious
minorities that are doubling their
numbers every 10 years what a great
recipe for a future world it's
interesting to think about what world
that creates yeah
I'm sure they want maybe a vision mate
no it'll be fine maybe it's not a big
problem maybe it's such a slow-moving
emergency that the equilibrium will
shift and you know it's kind of not
something to worry about but
uh but maybe
I don't know maybe it changes the
fundamental fabric of society if you
have like
40 of America's ambition like the year
3000 or something if America still
exists anyway but that I mean I don't
know that that's something to
that I think more people should be
thinking about
Coleman it's been an absolute pleasure
as always if people want to find you
online if people want to discover your
work where's the best way to do that
listen to my podcast conversations with
Coleman
uh check out my music cold man spelled
c-o-l-d-x-m-a-n the x is silent I have
three music videos out the latest one is
with Neil deGrasse Tyson I got to do a
cameo so you can listen to my music
wherever you listen to music watch my
videos on YouTube and follow me on
Twitter at coldx man
common here's thanks so much for coming
on and thank you guys for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
Aurora show and of course make sure you
check out the bonus questions with
Coleman on locals if they're only
available as on locals so if you want to
see them you've got to sign up for that
but also if you like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast thank you so much for tuning in
and see you soon guys
[Music]
Coleman with the benefit of hindsight
would you still vote for Biden
[Music]
foreign
[Music]